in the end I know there are number of
things that happened a number of
components a number of components and
I'm sure I may not even quite understand
to this day why I left but certainly it
was only afterwards that I realized
there must be some connection between my
father's death in 1985 and and my
leaving there in 1986 which just hadn't
struck me at the time but you know part
of the reason I was holding on was you
know at some level to be near him there
was also the fact that I met and fell in
love with a woman who we lived in
Belfast for a while
but it was not necessarily her favorite
spot there was also the fact that my job
much as I loved us really was it was
coming to the point where it was
extremely demanding particularly working
in television you know waking up in the
middle of the night wondering if it was
gonna rain the next day for example that
kind of concerned that the television
folk have that you know I realized that
I probably would not be able to write to
the extent that I that I would like even
though I've poetry was or the thing that
was most of interest to me and even
though actually I spend very little time
writing poetry and never have spent much
time writing poetry physically in terms
of the number of ours and the year even
so I felt somehow it was time time to
move time to go on also I was asked
coincidentally if I were pretty much
coincidentally anyhow if I'd like to
come over here and do some teaching over
here to the US that's to say
so there were a number of things coming
together and you know it's I still feel
very close to the place very close to it
and go back there all the time
it now is extraordinarily easy to hop in
a plane in Newark of an evening and five
six maybe five or six hours later
depending on the winds once in Belfast
is a direct flight develop fast from New
York and that makes one sense of one's
place very different my thing not so
long ago when my cousins or my uncle's
or my neighbors were coming over to the
u.s. in this in the 20th century and of
course in earlier centuries the chances
of there ever been able to afford to
come back were slender the length of
time it took to come back was large so
it was a much different proposition so
for the moment anyhow of course he knows
when oil runs out how it's gonna be but
for the moment it's comparatively easy
to get back and forth and this sense to
in which you know I lived there after I
was 35 and left so I've been here for
more than 20 years there you know so
much of it comes with one it's it's
ingrained in me I mean I know even now I
know the country very very well I mean I
just my sense of it is very good in
terms of you know what that road looks
like between wherever and wherever and
in whichever country of Ireland though
it's changed a lot to whose but much has
remained the same
you